there's really not much you need to do
to get your application to use memcache
to save and get entity data if you're
using objectify but it's still useful to
know how to write code to use memcache
so we're going to use memcache to save
and get announcements about conferences
that are nearly sold out you can imagine
for example that your web app might
display a banner ad to encourage people
to sign up for conferences that are
nearly sold out there might be other
things you want to announce on your
website too maybe if you get a special
speaker for a particular conference or
you want to announce a special promotion
but for the sake of simplicity we're
just going to create announcements about
conferences that are nearly sold out
because the goal here is to learn how to
use memcache announcements though are a
good example of the kind of thing that
you might want to save in memcache
without saving them to the data store if
the announcement gets evicted from
memcache there's no loss of real data
and it doesn't really matter no business
transactions are affected no one loses
their place at a conference and the next
announcement will likely come along very
soon anyway announcements are very
transient and don't need to be saved for
the long term and they don't need to be
backed up so they're perfect candidates
to be saved in memcache and only in
memcache they don't need to go in the
datastore that way you get all your
announcements without using any quota so
you're going to be adding the
announcement class to your project it's
a very simple class we need it because
endpoint functions can't return string
objects so we're going to put the text
for the announcement in the message
field note that this class is not
annotated as at entity we don't want to
save the announcements in the datastore